what your favorite memories from the
Empire Strikes Back well I suppose I
don't really have an L it's such a short
time you know we all were us us
underlings I got a good crack of the
whip
I suppose my best bit was my that
conversation I have with Darth Vader
which you know he showed he had a bit of
guts in that and wasn't an absolute
toady and the way he speaks to Darth
Vader when he was actually doing his
fighting is quite tough it wasn't much
fun to do it was it was sort of rather
routine being in a funny sort of super
galactic series we had no idea what it
would it was the second and so the first
one I've been successful where we had no
idea it was going to be what it is now
they wouldn't made it even any more
entertaining to do if we had known but I
mean everyone's very nice to her so but
no complaints but it was very routine
ordinary work nothing exciting about it
at all I'm for instance
I hadn't seen when I was doing the
fighting up in my attack I'm and I
wasn't in one of those I was in a gantry
on a sort of a sort of lift thing and
there was a mock-up of a control panel
in front of me a blue screen behind me
and they just tickled that about a bit
and I had no idea and I didn't know what
I was actually fighting with until I saw
the film I didn't know it was that
extraordinary mechanical giraffe I had
no idea and it was it was rather like
that but everyone it was nice because
the actors and I've kept up this pride a
lot of the act like Ken Kali and people
and and Jeremy Bulloch
and that's been good and I've made much
more money out of these conventions than
I did out of making Star Wars I've paid
200 pounds of Star Wars and we all were
we had four days five days on it
something like that and we in and out we
went and didn't think about it again
until suddenly whoa hello it's such a
huge franchise the husband for years as
well I mean what do you think about it
coming back well good luck to it
I think it's lost its original zest it's
now a very very clever it's brilliantly
done I can't deny that the special
effects are simply remarkable
but it's lost its original zest because
it's lost its its soul and it has to
have lost its soul we all now know about
the force and those things which made
our lagunas do it
and those things which are under the
surface but which actually drives the
human being all right that's actually a
very high level but it that's why I
listened it was so successful very wise
people look who look very funny and like
toads and things and and and animals
animal creatures who have great
intelligence and can move and do things
that we can't and that was originally
very good and then but and I think the
first four were really good and now as I
say they're very well done but they're
not the same thing I noticed that your
son had turned the voice of ears in some
Star Wars video games do you think he'd
like to be involved in the new Star Wars
coming back my son does me as you know
in the video games and as you say I'd
like to come back in the new Star Wars
or somebody else or like Devere or like
veers having grown up a bit and an old
old veers and that that'll be good
you